the bloopers from The Avengers films
might be some of the funniest we've seen
in a while in fact they're so funny that
it's hard not to fall in love with the
films all over again in the realm of
superheroes especially Norse mythology
derived superheroes you're only as good
as your accessories Thor has quite a few
his long red cape his long blond hair
and his mighty hammer Mjolnir when it
comes to his hammer it's so tough and
unbreakable that it took the might of
hella the goddess of death to finally
break it in Thor Ragnarok maybe they got
the idea for that moment from this
blooper man which Thor's magical hammer
sure seems like a very breakable prop
one of the few things as iconic is
Thor's hammer in the MCU is Captain
America's shield
it's about as classic as superhero of
equipment gets and it's so powerful that
camp routinely bust through walls and
locks with it unfortunately the real
prop shield they use in the filming is a
lot less useful than its fictional
counterpart it's easy for the comic book
version of Bruce Banner to just rattle
off scientific terms because someone can
just scribble them into a speech bubble
it's clearly a bit harder for actors to
say all those complicated words in real
life just watch Mark Ruffalo as he
struggles to deliver what's clearly a
mouth full of technical mumbo-jumbo in
the Avengers age of Ultron clear potent
cells inside a silo pluripotent cells
into his eyeline settle in a deleted
scene in Iron Man 3 Trevor Slattery
successfully passes himself off as a
Russian over the phone which leads to
Colonel James Rhodes asking him to try
out a number of other voices it's really
just a chance for Academy award-winning
actors Sir Ben Kingsley to display his
acting ability and dialect talent
because he can handle every suggestion
actor Don Cheadle throws his way did you
make him gay I come from Jamaica hey can
you do French I love just before say can
you do like a Spanish I can do buddy
shut up well almost every suggestion can
you do a British well I'm British
when Bruce Banner turns into the Hulk to
punch a giant alien in the Avengers it's
a stand up and clap moment however as it
turns out that wasn't exactly the first
instinct that actor Mark Ruffalo had
when facing down a CGI monstrosity
[Music]
considering how terrifying the aliens
looked on the big screen it's hard to
fault Ruffalo's acting instincts Paul
Bettany used to just provide the voice
of Jarvis in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but these days he's using his
whole self to play vision Bettany is
barely recognizable under all that red
makeup while he certainly looks the part
of the super advanced robot he's acting
more like a malfunctioning computer in
this blooper from Captain America Civil
War as maximum 11 LM have some
competition in his maximum manipulates
molecular allow her to go for one of the
most impressive things about the MCU is
that the actors are able to take it all
seriously when surrounded by goofy
costumes and CGI monsters it's the kind
of true commitment to character that
explains why they get paid so much
however that doesn't mean there aren't a
few moments where that seriousness cuts
out in this lineup of stern determined
looking heroes for Avengers infinity war
Benedict Wong just couldn't keep the
steely resolve in a space for more than
a few seconds
spider-man homecoming included one of
the most memorable cameos in MCU history
when Chris Evans is Captain America pops
in via green screened video to deliver
some corny educational advice to the
students of Peters high school so you
got detention you screwed up however one
particular video is just a bit too over
the top for Evans to make it through
without cracking up hi i'm captain
america whether you're a student or a
soldier there's one thing that will
always give you an edge a hot lunch
ant-man in the wasp was packed with
plenty of car chases through San
Francisco a city full of steep hills big
curves and tons of traffic in this
blooper Paul Rudd gets into character as
he prepares to shoot one of those
sequences good seeing everyone let's
have fun with this one best scene in the
movie an MCU movie made in the last few
years just wouldn't be complete without
a Stan Lee appearance an ant-man and the
wasp had one of the legendary creators
best cameos as Scott Lang hope Van Dyne
and their associates battled bad guys
through the twisty streets of San
Francisco Lee shows up as a guy whose
car gets shrunk by ant man's signature
technology
well the 60s were fun but now I'm paying
for it it turns out that's just the take
filmmakers decided on they had Lee go
through a huge list of funny
possibilities I know my sandwich was in
there well at least now I'll be able to
park in San Francisco the two ant-man
movies are pretty much the funniest of
all the MCU standalone flicks a cast of
both feature performers with a knack for
comedy including Walton Goggins Michael
Pena Randall Park and Judy Greer even so
it's a pleasant surprise for viewers to
suddenly encounter Tim Heidecker a
comedy innovator known for his bizarre
boundary-pushing work on cult TV
favorites like Tim and Eric awesome show
great job an ant-man in the wasp he
plays the leader of a San Francisco Bay
boat tour guide some of heidecker's best
lines were unfortunately left for the
blooper reel
I freaked for Wales I loved them ever
since I was a kid I'm not trained really
in biology or knowing anything about
them I've memorized a couple of facts
but I couldn't go deep black panther is
a crowning achievement in filmmaking and
it also gave the world one of the
all-time great movie catchphrases it
even makes an appearance in Avengers
infinity war since Black Panthers
release in early 2018 millions have
flashed each other the crossed arms
salute by now everyone knows how to say
what Conda correctly but during the
film's production a few cast members had
trouble getting it down in this clip
neither Martin Freeman nor Danai gurira
are confident in their ability that
thing that was on your arm is from
Wakanda what condiment Doctor Strange
was a harder sell than your typical
superhero movie after all dr. Stephen
strangest powers come from an ability to
connect with the worlds of mysticism and
magic to effectively ground that in
reality the filmmakers required the
services of an actor with extensive
classical training and an impressive
resume full of award-winning dramatic
roles that actor Benedict Cumberbatch
who earned widespread acclaim for his
work and Sherlock and the imitation game
but who knew that Cumberbatch could be
so silly underneath all the pomp and
circumstance he's just as goofy on set
as a whacky comic actor judging from
this blooper reel he's especially down
to get down breaking into dance routines
while filming his scenes
it's apparently contagious because most
of his co-stars got in on the dance
craze too
one of televisions longest-running hits
is America's Funniest Home Videos
debuting in 1990 this long-running
series has delighted the masses with
miles of poorly shot and grainy footage
of grown men getting hit in the private
parts the MCU movies for all their
big-budget set pieces aren't immune to
that simple joy getting included on the
blooper reel did I get your testicle in
the 80s and 90s Jeff Goldblum brought a
disarming charm and off-center
sensibility to his roles and otherwise
straightforward movies like Jurassic
Park and Independence Day in doing so he
made them much better than it would have
otherwise been without him it makes
sense then that when director Taika
Waititi took the thor movies in a cosmic
and comedic direction with thor ragnarok
he brought Goldblum in for a role
Goldblum plays the grand master the most
hedonistic of all the elders of the
universe the actor brings his trademark
looseness and an almost jazz like
approach to the movie which is
noticeable even when he's goofing off
between takes watch this
lo can take it away
Thor's wardrobe is about as eye-catching
as the lightning that often accompanies
the character in addition to Chris
Hemsworth's own indisputable good looks
Thor usually rocks a tight metal shirt
red pants and one undeniably great cape
but while the accessory might be stylish
it can be pretty temperamental on the
set of Thor the dark world
Hemsworth tries his best to act but he
has trouble due to an unpredictable
co-star his cape science fiction films
and superhero movies are full of
mythology backstory and their own sets
of rules Iron Man 3 is a sci-fi film as
well as the superhero movie and it's got
a lot of specific words and jargon it's
actors need to clearly and slowly
deliver so the action around them makes
sense it's a delicate balance to nail
the terminology that's been part of a
comic or cinematic universe for years so
it satisfies both hardcore and new fans
alike that's why Marvel and its
filmmakers hire top-notch talent to
deliver the written lines actors like
Robert Downey jr. have the training
skill and talent necessary to say all
the technical talk in a believable way
still sometimes it's hard to get those
words out because even for an actor of
Downey's caliber there's a lot to
remember in Iron Man 3 Tony Stark has to
recall his various super suits there are
a lot of them and in this blooper Downey
jr. needs the assistance of the
heartbreaker armor to help out the armor
whose name escapes him heartbreaker will
you help what's his name snapper while
the MCU movies enjoy a lot of cast
overlap for the various super heroic
characters black panther came out of
nowhere to introduce many fantastic
characters to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it also had the added benefit
of making huge stars out of the actors
and actresses who portrayed them
chadwick boseman had attained some fame
after playing Jackie Robinson and James
Brown and 42 and get on up respectively
while Lapita Nyong'o achieved her
breakthrough with 12 years of slave now
they're a listers thanks to their roles
at the top of the cast of the
superhero action blockbuster Danai
gurira established a big screen career
for herself beyond her role as the
katana wielding Michonne on The Walking
Dead but in this blooper she's quickly
and effectively upstaged by yet another
breakout MCU star a goat no you have
found something check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]